nothing draws a crowd like a new baby
tourists line up to see what are
arguably the most adorable animals on
earth all in one place
I'm Amy Vitali here in China at the
chengdu research base for giant panda
breeding photographing 11 of these
squeaky Cubs pandas are one of the most
recognized animals on the planet but
what you might not know is how elusive
and mysterious they are
[Music]
incredibly they survived for millions of
years largely unknown to mankind and
proof of the pandas existence didn't
spread beyond China until 1869 the world
has been hard on giant pandas as the
landscape has changed their numbers have
fallen to unsustainable lows in the wild
they were considered dangerously close
to extinction and scientists weren't
able to breed them in captivity the
Bears are picky about whom to love and
when but now after decades of hard work
and research there's a glimmer of hope
Chinese scientist with help from
international colleagues have learned a
few tricks of their own China now has
their hands on the pulse of panda
breeding and their efforts have filled
Chengdu and other similar centers with
hundreds of valuable little lives and
they're learning how to put these newly
made pandas into the wild landscape
giving hope to an entire species the
wild isn't what it once was to truly get
pandas on their feet will mean
rejuvenating the forested mountain
environment where it no longer suits the
Bears protecting the land that still
panda friendly and growing new trees
where it's not giving the Bears back
space that was once theirs and then
stepping away to let them flourish
naturally knowledge about what pandas
need to thrive is growing and so are the
baby pandas it's now up to all of us to
lift these delightful creatures clear of
danger
you